well it is a beautiful spring day and me
and Tommy and Nathan and mommy and we're
all going to meet for lunch take a
little break from work to go and eat out
somewhere nice and I think we're going
to try some oysters you want to try some
oysters Tommy yeah all right let's give
it a go hey Mason you want to eat some
oysters
all right let's get some oysters hey
Tommy Tommy you want to get some oysters
together yeah
all right okay but I like it taking them
give them for ice and noise all right
let's do it
give me one of the oysters okay I'm
causing trouble buddy maybe that'll bail
you out
hi Dixon you never had this before so
we'll see what happens yeah you've never
had reach here before
come try this
[Music]
you like that yeah it's like oh yeah it
is like so did called root beer I take
my Tony pocket this tastes like Tom if I
steer nobody oh yeah no that's pretty
good so mom strawberry are you like it's
very limited
[Music]
you like that wanna check this out here
good here what this is I will you this
is just a little bit you want you want
to use one okay hold it you want to put
some sauce oh don't hope you dropped it
this is the part you eat okay hold on so
take this put a little bit of this sauce
on okay no go ahead and do is go and you
just slurp it up giggle yes yeah tastes
like the ocean it does taste like the
ocean here Tom you try this one let's
see it slurp it up
[Music]
here you go go and slip that the Holy
Ghost cool check it up you got it what
do you think time you like him go on try
some more
give me buddy I'll try it oh yes look
right be sure sure what what are you
doing you want me to try Dead Island MC
that was empty here try this one this
one's got stuff in it I don't take it
home on me yes you're right
he's a little high I tried
WI eat it no good and you are you okay
oh yeah you idiot all right you want to
try this last one come to me
Nathan you walked right nope he's fine
you tell me like right nope all right
time you like your chicken tenders
french fries a little better yeah that's
what's up
Irma borrows dominations root beer
like a spaghetti I get the Thea
you want to try this that's a lemon
lemon